now i'd like to share the top six
i would call them more biohacking
modalities that i really believe in and
that i've tested and that i've used or
i've done and i think they're really
beneficial number one i i totally
believe in the juve red light or
whatever red light you want i really
believe in that um i think it actually i
don't know call me crazy i feel like it
almost changes the texture of my skin
and makes it smoother um but it's
helping your mitochondrial function and
mitochondria is the the powerhouse of
the cell that creates energy so anything
that we can do to help with the
mitochondria is a good idea so red light
i'm sticking with it um
number two
is infrared sauna there's lots of lots
of uh good data out there about all of
the more nitty gritty details and what
the infrared sauna does but in general
it's really good for cardiovascular
cardiovascular health and it's also
really good for detoxing and i think in
this sort of day and age that we live in
it's almost impossible to avoid um
toxins like we're walking outside of our
car we're getting on an airplane you
name it it's there's toxins and so to
conjoin the sauna with also a little bit
of binder too i think is a great great
practice charcoal clay something like
that to uh to bind the bind it bind to
um so that the heavy metals get
excreted number three magnesium you know
magnesium is just one of those things
it's kind of hard to get enough of
even in all of my blood tests and
testing magnesium is something that has
been low in me even with supplementation
so i would say that probably magnesium
is another really
really great added
supplement that
it's hard to get enough of
that really helps you with to feel
better energy function
they're helpful for detoxification
pathways too so magnesium great one
number four uh vitamin d plus k2 vitamin
d is something especially i think that
if they say if you're north of
i don't even know might be like atlanta
georgia or something it's pretty far
south but if you're north anywhere of
that that for a for a general portion of
the year when it's obviously cold and
and snowy in some spots you're just not
going to be able to get vitamin d you're
going to have to supplement it so
there's some places you can get enough
vitamin d but even for me living in
arizona i still didn't get enough
vitamin d and i mean i go outside i
don't even wear sunscreen so like even
if there was an idea that sunscreen is
blocking vitamin d absorption i don't
really wear any so
um
so i think a vitamin d supplement is an
excellent thing to add on to your
regular protocol
number five uh the quality of your water
so i'm talking about everything from the
way from what it comes in to what you
put in it so um i currently have a
little protocol with um my oh my god my
giant giant jug my gallon jug of water
um where i add in um minerals uh i add
in um sometimes i put electrolytes in
there too
um so i just like stack my water i use a
reverse osmosis system um to really
clean the water but of course when you
clean it just like if you clean the body
you redo you get rid of other things too
so um you're reducing the mineral
content by nature with reverse osmosis
so minerals electrolytes um but really
looking at the the the water itself and
then the the container it's in like
i can't tell you how worried i was how
many friggin bottles of plastic bottles
of water i drank in my career like i
just got handled another water bottle
and then another water bottle and
another water bottle and that's what i
drank in my bust when i be traveling and
i try and do a better job of refilling
water bottles not defaulting to getting
a bottle of water out somewhere i don't
care if it's your essentia or whatever
evian like it's still in a plastic
bottle so as much as you can do to get
your water into into glass and into
water bottles reducing plastics i think
is a great idea so quality of the water
is important thera-body boots okay so
when i trained for the marathon um
my friend got these thera-body boots we
went to the crossfit games and she loved
them and i thought okay fine and they
just pressurize from your foot from your
toes all the way up to the top of your
leg and they release and they just keep
cycling it
and um to sort of flush your legs out
and and get them to um not feel so sore
and so i didn't really believe in the
boots until
her and i ran it was the last run we did
in chicago and it was i think we did
like 16 miles or something like that it
was kind of like the last long run we
had already done 20 so it was like a
little bit less maybe we ran 14.
it was kind of a warm day get back we
slip into the boots and i mean my legs
are pretty sore and running the 16 and
the 18 and the 20 like my legs could be
were pretty sore um but i put them in
after that and i went from not really
being able to walk very well to
walking
just fine and i was like okay wow
these things work so especially like
right after a hard workout especially
obviously if it's lower body
it's insanely beneficial i'm talking
about if you're doing your biking
running
weight lifting you name it anything with
the lower body that's taxing put these
boots on afterwards for i mean i put it
of course at like 30 minutes max
pressure um but anyway it works so thera
body boots are awesome so those are my
top six the
red light infrared sauna magnesium
vitamin d
quality water and fair body boots